اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
اللجنه الرباعيه تاخذ اجتماعين منفصلين مع
البرهان ودلو في مساعد جديده للتهدئه على
خلفيه احداث
وتوقعاتهم بتظاهر نحو 600 الف محتج على
قانون التقاعد الجديد في فرنسا والنقابات
تجتمع قبل قرار المجلس الدستوري للبته في
القبر
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن ان اخوات فادنير
مستمره في طرد القوات الاوكرانيه خارج
ضخمه وكيف تنشر فيديو لجنودها في المدينه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه ما
تزال الازمه في السودان تتفاعل دون التوصل
الى تسويه حتى الساعه تنزع فتيله التوتر
في البلاد
اللجنه الرباعيه التي تضم الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه وبريطانيا والامارات
ستعقد اجتماعي لمنفصلين مع البرهان ودجلو
للتهدئه
هذا في حين ذكر مراسل العربيه الاجتماع
اليوم لمجلس الامن والدفاع السوداني على
خلفيه احداث مروي
وقد افاد مراسل العربيه بانتهاء الاجتماع
الذي دعا اليه حزب الامه والذي ضم قوى غير
موقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
واضاف ان القوه المدنيه التي حضرت
الاجتماع شكلت لجنه من قدامى المحاربين
للتواصل مع البرهان
كما قرر المجتمعون عقد جلسه اخرى يوم غد
تضم نسبه اكبر من القوى السياسيه لوضع
تصور موحد وواضح حول مجريات الاحداث
ومستقبل العمليه السياسيه في السودان
الى ذلك افاد مراسل العربيه بدخول اثنتين
وخمسين اعربه تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
الى منطقه مروي شمال العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم
وتاتي التطورات في ظل التصاعد التوترات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريه في ولايه
مروي الشماليه هذا فيما اكد الجيش
السوداني ان حشد قوات الدعم السريع
فالخرطوم ومناطق اخرى في البلاد جاء دون
موافقه او تنسيق مع قياده القوات المسلحه
في الولايه الشماليه بالسودان تحديدا في
مدينه مروي يبدو المشهد متوترا وقد ياخذ
البلاد الى هويه العنف عقب الحشود الاخيره
لقوات الدعم السريع التي قابلها الجيش
بتحرك مماثل المدينه الواقعه على الضفه
الجنوبيه للنهر النيل تحتوي على مطار دولي
واحدى اهم القواعد الجويه للجيش السوداني
التوتر الذي تشهده المدينه جاء بعد حشد
قوات الدعم السريع قرابه 100 اليه عسكريه
تحديدا في محيط القاعده الجويه جنوب
المدينه امر دفع الجيش السوداني الى تحشيد
قواته في القاعده الجويه ومحيطها
الجيش السوداني اعتبر تحرك الدعم السريع
مخالفا للقانون ويضع البلاد في منعطف وصفه
بالخطير والتاريخ الى سيما انه جرى دون
موافقته هذه الانفتاحات واعاده تمركز
القوات
يخالف مهام ونظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
وفيه تجاوز واضح
للقانون ومخالفه لتوجيهات اللجان الامنيه
المركزيه والولائيه واستمرارها سيؤدي حتما
الى المزيد من الانقسامات والتوترات التي
ربما تقود الى انفراط عقد الامن بالبلاد
تقول المعلومات ان القوات الدعم السريعه
تريد الانقضاض على المطار العسكري الاهم
للجيش في الشمال لافشال اي تحرك جوي للجيش
وعبر سلاح الطيران اذا وقعت المواجهه
منذ مطلع الشهر الجاري بدا الجيش ببناء
السور ومرافق في الارض المحاذيه لمطار
المدينه امر قد يفسر سبب التحرك قوات
الدعم السريع التي يقودها حميدتي ومع
توارد الانباء عما تشهده ماروي بدات القوه
السياسيه والمدنيه تحركات المكوكيه
لاحتواء الموقف موقف منصف بالخطير ووصل
مرحله ما قبل الطلقه الاولى
لمزيد من المتابعه حول كل هذه التطورات
معي من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي
نزار اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه نزار جديد
المشهد المتوتر في محيط قاعده مروي الجويه
وهل الامور تنبي بسيناريوهات دراماتيكيه
في الساعات المقبله بين الطرفين
كل شيء قابل للتنفيذ على ارض الواقع اذا
ما استمر التحشيد والتحشيد المضاد على بعد
500 كم فقط من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
هنالك الاجواء متوتره في منطقه مروي حيث
القاعده الجويه العسكريه السودانيه في تلك
الولايه شمال السودان بعد ان وصلت قوات
الدعم السريع الى تلك المنطقه الان
الاجتماع الذي عقد ظهور هذا اليوم لجنه
امن الولايه الشماليه
دفع بعدد من التوصيات ابرز هذه التوصيات
اهميه ضبط النفس اهميه ان تستجيب قوات
الدعم السريع للمهله التي منحت لها من قبل
القوات السودانيه قوات الجيش السوداني
بالانسحاب من تلك المنطقه هذا على ارض
الواقع هنالك ايضا حشود من قبل مواطنين في
منطقه مروي وهي المدينه التي
تحاذي هذه القاعده الجويه هنالك تجمهورات
من المواطنين يطالبون قوات الدعم السريع
بالانسحاب فورا من المنطقه التي وصلت
اليها يوم الامس اما هنا في السودان
فالتحركات العاجله من قبل الفاعلين
السياسيين من قبل القوى السياسيه لنزع
فتيل الازمه الابرز وهي العنوان العريض
نحن الان اجزاء اجتماعات متواصله من قبل
الفاعلين الدوليين هو الحريه والتغيير
تحديدا حزب الامه القومي الان يحضر خلال
الساعات المقبله للاجتماع الثاني بعد
ساعات من الاجتماع الاول الذي انقضى صباح
هذا اليوم يرتب الاجتماع [__] نسبه اكبر
من القوى السياسيه سواء كان الذين وقعوا
على الاتفاق الاطار او الممانعين او
الرافضين في مسعن ايضا لنزع فتيل الازمه
بعد ان وصلت الامور الى وضع يقول حزب
الامه بانه يجب ان يخضع للراي ولحكمه
السودانيين طيب نزار ساسالك بعد قليل عن
جهود هذه الوساطات وهل ستملك فرصه ولكن ما
يعني فقط لنفهم المشاهدين ما عدا مما بدا
لتندلع الازمه بهذا الشكل
بين الطرفين المدججين بالسلاح اذ لطالما
تغنى كل طرف بالطرف الاخر بالحلف التاريخي
والحديد بينهما
وسوى ذلك من مصطلحات ما عدا مما بدا
لتنفجر هذه الازمه بهذا الشكل
يكمن الشيطان في التفاصيل عندما بدا
الاتفاق لطارف الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي
كانت كل الامور تمضي على ما يرام داخل
كبينه القياده سواء كان داخل القياده
العامه للجيش او قياده الدعم السريع لكن
عندما مضت الامور نحو تنفيذ بنود الاتفاق
الاطاري الذي النص صراحه على جيش قومي
وطني واحد يعتمر بعقيده واحده هنا دخلت
التفاصيل ما هي ما هي وضعيه قوات الدعم
السريع من سيسيطر على الدعم السريع من
سيدضع لقوات الدعم السريع هذه التفاصيل
اضيف اليها ايضا التصريحات التي صدرت من
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان ومن عضو
مجلس السياده شمس الدين كباشي وعديد
القيادات العسكريه عندما قال الصراحه بانه
اذا اراد السياسيون ان يمضوا مع العسكريين
في اتفاق
سياسي فعل الاتفاق الايطالي ان يضمن دمج
قوات الدعم السريع داخل المنظومه العسكريه
وهنا الحديث عن الجيش السوداني هنا
التفاصيل وهنا وضعيه الدعم السريع من يتبع
سنوات دمج الدعم السريع في المنظومه
العسكريه عشر سنوات خمس سنوات سنتان كل
هذه التفاصيل ابرزت نوع من التباين بين
العياده الجيش وابرز نوع من الخصومه
السياسيه داخل المنظومه العسكريه سواء كان
في الدعم السريع او داخل الجيش نزار سؤال
الاخير هل تشهد الخرطوم اي حاله استنفار
وايضا يعني هل تملك وساطه رئيس حزب الامه
اي فرصه ام لا يعني الامور معقده باختصار
باختصار الان حزب الامه يسعى كغيره من
القوى السياسيه كالرباعيه الدوليه كبعض
القوى السياسيه الاصوات تدعو الى تهدئه
الناس تدعو الى ضبط الخطاب تدعو الى عدم
مواصله البيانات والبيانات المضاده
الخرطوم الان تشهد هدوءا بالحذر هنالك
تحركات لاليات عسكريه منتشره على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ولكن ليس هنالك توضيح
رسمي سواء من الدعم السريع او من الجيش
حول طبيعه هذه التحركات والى اين تمضي
والى اين تتجه ولكن الان الاوضاع في
السوداء في الخرطوم تحديدا اؤكد بانها
تمضي على ما يرام وهنالك حاله من الهدوء
والكره الان يتوقع بيانات تفصيليه واضافيه
توضحي الى اين ستمضي هذه الازمه المتفاقمه
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع من الخرطوم
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي شكرا جزيلا لك
نزار على كل هذه المتابعه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
ارتفاع ضحايا غرق قارب للهجره امام سواحل
صفاقس في تونس الى خمسه وعشرين شخصا
اهلا بكم من جديد يبدا الفرنسيون جوله
جديده من الاضراب والتظاهر ضد قانوني رفع
سن التقاعد الجديد وذلك في احدث دعوه
للاحتجاج عشيه قرار حاسم للمجلس الدستوري
بشان هذا المشروع وتعتبر جوله احتجاجات
اليوم الثانيه عشره خلال ثلاثه اشهر التي
تقرر النقابات الفرنسيه تنظيمها وتاتي
عشيه مصادقه اعضاء المجلس الدستوري على
قرار رفع سن التقاعد القانونيه من 62 عاما
الى 64 عاما والمقرر ان يصدر الاسبوع
المقبل
مع من باريس الاهلي مزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه فادي دهوك فادي اهلا وسهلا
بك كيف يبدو مشهد التظاهرات والاحتجاجات
من عندك في هذه الاوقات وهل نتوقع ليله
طويله من المواجهات فادي
اهلا طالب نعم هذا امر متوقع بشكل كبير
الان هناك بعض المناوشات المحدوده جدا
تجري في الموكب الباريسي في جزء من هذا
الموكب نحن الان في راس التظاهره لكن هناك
كما ارى استخدام للغاز المسيل للدموع ان
كنتم تتمكنون من رؤيه ذلك على الشاشه
الاشتباكات محدوده جدا حتى الان لكن من
المتوقع ان يكون هذا اليوم طويل لانه ياتي
قبل يوم حاسم من قرار المجلس الدستوري حول
شرعيه او دستوريه قانون رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما هذا الراي الدستوري سوف يخرج
عن المجلس يوم غدا كما ان المتظاهرين انهم
على هم في محيط موقع المجلس الذي لحظيه
اليوم بانتشار امني مكثف جدا واستثنائي
هناك مئات عناصر الشرطه التي تحمي مقر
المجلس الدستوري الواقع على بعد امتار
قليله من هذه المنطقه وهنا طالب طيب فادي
ولكن
هل لدى المتظاهرين النقابات مؤشرات من ان
المجلس الدستوري سيقر مشروع القانون كما
ورد من الحكومه والرئاسه الفرنسيه لذلك هم
يتظاهرون في محاوله للضغط ام لا لا مؤشرات
حتى الساعه عن طبيعه القرار الذي سيتخذه
المجلس الدستوري فيما خص هذه القضيه
نعم حتى الان لا يمكن معرفه القرار الذي
سيتخذه المجلس الدستوري لكن كما ذكرت
النقابات تحاول الضغط في محاوله للتاثير
على القرار ان يكن لكن التظاهرات سوف
تستمر مهما كان راي المجلس الدستوري هذا
ما صرحت به النقابات وايضا الاحزاب
السياسيه مختلفه ايضا بعد القرار الرئيس
الفرنسي اعلن انه سيقوم بدعوه النقابات
لكي يبداوا بالتشاور طبعا هذه الدعوه حتى
الان لقيت رفضا من النقابات هناك على سبيل
المثال الكونفدراليه العامه للعمل صرحت
السكرتيره العامه لها اليوم وقالت ان لا
يوجد لديهم الوقت ليضيعونه مع الرئيس
لانهم اصلا كانوا قد طرحوا هذه الفكره
ورفضها الرئيس في وقت سابق لذلك يعتبرون
ان مساله الحوار بعد صدور قرار المجلس
الدستوري لن تغير شيئا في موقفهم
وسيواصلون التظاهر مهما كان هذا القرار
طيب في حال اقر المجلس الدستوري كما يتوقع
البعض هذا القانون كما ورد اي
السيناريوهات المتوقعه هل الامور ستكون
على مذهب الى الشارع در والكلمه ستكون
للشارع مع ما يعنيه الشارع في هذه الاوقات
في فرنسا
اقرار القانون من قبل المجلس الدستوري
سيكون او سيتبع تحركا واسعا جدا من
النخبات هذا ما تقوله النقبات ومعظم
الاحزاب اليساريه المعارضه يقولون ان مهما
كان قرار المجلس سواء كان بتمرير مشروع
القانون كاملا او باجزاء منه سوف يستمرون
في التظاهر لكن مساله ان يقوم المجلس
الدستوري باصدار موافقه على هذا القانون
او مشروع القانون ربما سيعطي دفعه كبيره
جدا للشارع لكي تستمر هذه التظاهرات ونصل
الى مرحله ربما مرحله تعطيل كامل وشل
اقتصاد البلاد هذا ما تحذر منه النقبات
ومعظم الاحزاب اليساريه المعارضه يقولون
ان حركه الاحتجاج لن تتوقف اذا ما قام
المجلس الدستوري باقرار هذا القانون وهذا
ربما ايضا محاوله للضغط والتاثير على راي
من يسمون الحكماء في المجلس الدستوري يعني
التجمعات من وراءك تزداد
فادي ابرز المدن التي ستشهد تظاهرات
واعتصاماتك التي نشهدها في باريس هل من
معلومات
التظاهرات خرجت في معظم المدن الفرنسيه
هناك تظاهرات انتهت بالفعل خصوصا في مدن
جنوب البلاد مثل مارسيليا وتولوز يبقى
وتبقى العين على العاصمه باريس لان الموكب
الاكبر يخرج هنا وكما ترون هناك موكب كبير
جدا من الاشخاص الان هناك ربما عمليه
محاوله لتفرقه هذا الموكب ليس تفرقه لكي
يعود هؤلاء المتظاهرون الى منازلهم ولكن
ليتمكنوا من السيطره على هذا الموكب لان
الاعداد ضخمه جدا الشرطه تقوم بتقسيم
الموكب الى مواكب حتى تسمح بتقدم بعض
المتظاهرين ثم تقوم بالسماح لاخرين
بالتقدم طبعا هذه المنطقه هي حساسه جدا
هنا نحن على بعد امتار قريره قليله من
متحف اللوفر ايضا وكذلك من المجلس
الدستوري لذلك هناك حساسيه امنيه لهذا
الموقع والشرطه متواجده بكثافه كما ترون
على الشاشه
من باريس مراسل العربيه فادي دهوك شكرا
جزيلا لك فادي على كل هذه المتابعه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوات
فارغنار مستمره في طرد القوات الاوكرانيه
خارج التجمعات الرئيسيه في
الروسيه كانت قد اعلنت انها استولت على
اكثر من ثمانين بالمئه من المدينه
هذا وقد اظهر مقطع مصور جنودا اوكرانيين
يتجولون في شوارع بخموت بعد اعلان قوه
فاجنر الروسيه السيطره على 80% من المدينه
[موسيقى]
يدلي الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بشهادته امام المدعي العامه في نيويورك
في تهم تتعلق بالتحايل من خلال التلاعب
بقيمه ممتلكات عقاريه للحصول على قروض
ميسره ومزايا ضريبيه
سجل الحرم المكي وما امس اكثر من مليون
ومئه الف مصلين
بارتفاع الاعداد خلال الايام العشره
الاخيره من رمضان
وتعتبر غرفه عمليات الرئاسه حلقه وصل بين
الجهات بالمسجد الحرام والادارات
الميدانيه التابعه للرئاسه كما تتم متابعه
كافه مناطق الحرم المكي عبر الشاشات
الامنيه المرتبطه بغرفه عمليات امن المسجد
الحرم
من الحرم المكي الشريف وناصر العربيه
اسامه القاسم هو معي الان اسامه اهلا
وسهلا بك جديد المشهد من عندك وابرز
مشاهداتك اليوم بسام
اهلا وسهلا طالب تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
مشاهدين العربيه انقل لكم الصوت والصور
اليوم من هنا بنصحنا المطاف بالحرم المكي
الشريف الذي يشهد الان امتلاء بالكامل
وتزاحم جديدا عندما داخل ومخارج صحن
المطافه اترككم الان مع كاميرا العربيه
لمشاهده هذه المشاهد وايضا نتحدث اكثر
وبشكل اوسع عن هذه الخدمات المقدمه اليوم
ضمن العشر الاواخر في الحرم المكي الشريف
نتحدث اليوم عن وصول اكثر من 950 الف زائر
ومعتمر باليوم الواحد حسب احصائيات رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين ما يدعو اليوم جميع الجهات
المتواجده لرفع الجاهزيه القصوى لاستقبال
ملايين الزوار والمعتمرين خلال العشر
الاواخر التي بالتاكيد ستشهد ازدحاما
شديدا وتوافدا اكثر لقوافل الزوار
والمعتمر ينتحدث اليوم اذا عن الطريق
الوصول الى الحرم المكي الشريف هناك اكثر
من 8000 حافله تنقل الزوار والمعتمرين الى
الحرم المكي الشريف هناك اكثر من سته
مداخل هذا المدخل الذي نشاهده الان باب
الملك عبد وايضا خمس مداخل اخرى مخصصه
للدخول الى المطاف وهناك ايضا سته ابواب
مخصصه للصلاه هناك ايضا تم تهيئه التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه لاستقبال ملايين الزوار
وقاصدين المسجد الحرام من المصلين نتحدث
اليوم على ان التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه
تتسع لاكثر من مليون ومئتين الف مصلي وسط
خدمات متكامله في جميع انحاء هذه التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن
الاعداد المليونيه التي تاتي اليوم الى
المسجد الحرام سبع احصائيات اخيره والتي
انت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين ان هناك اكثر من
20 مليون مصلي ومعتمر وصل الى المسجد
الحرام خلال الايام الماضيه وتوقعات ايضا
بان
تشهداما اشد واصولا لعدد الزوار
والمعتمرين مع الحرم المكي الشريف وراس
العربي اسامه القاسم شكرا جزيلا لك اسامه
على كل هذه المتابعه
ارتفعت حصيله ضحايا غرق مركب امام سواحل
تونس قبل يومين الى 25 شخصا بعد انتشال
خمسه عشره جثه جديده وقال حرس السواحل
التونسي انه تم انقاذه 72 مهاجرا غالبيتهم
من دول افريقيا
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات